bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fa vj e oggi siamo con thomas
che campione italiano di overwatch era
il campione italiano over bocce e
campioni e forte a ovvero c'è il
campione e ronaldo e facciamo 2 contro 2
con altri suoi amici che cambiano in
ogni tot
buona visione allora io scelgo un una
cosa che so fare bene che sparare ad
kazum quindi a perfetto le prendo questa
non avevo altra scelta se con questa
bene il primo che uccideva daniel suo
canale ragazzi e siccome si gioca così
ci giochiamo oggi disco unico nel poker
ci giochiamo un sacco di cose gli
iscritti tutto quanto 26 questo sei tu
sei luglio non dj brazilian stanchi
carlino maledizione mai vedere che mi
hanno ucciso
forse il campione del mondo di o latin
lover voci come hanno fatto uscire
dentista ma se dovessi ma non so dove si
ma nero incastonato nelle scale va bene
allora ogni morte per due milioni di
iscritti riguadagna qualcun altro per
forza ogni volta che adesso diciamo
tavole achilli riguadagni mi sembra
ottimo ma poi ti chiami al baretto ma
perché palace gioco quest'altro ma devo
fare questo perché mi trovo bene troppo
bene con juncker cioè noi herat è
l'unico di quelle il quale ho una skin
quindi non sembra un barbone però questa
vai vai vai vai a madrid dritti sul
pozzo che al centro della mappa o altra
che bravo è bravo è bravo l'ha visto che
ha poca vita occhio ad occhio non farti
prendere che le fa diventa un casino per
fatto che amy fatti mi ha fatto un po
male però
ma perché civile dove che male questa
amo sono allora ragazzi dobbiamo fare
dobbiamo fare un po di mesi di training
python
non lo so che ce la fai il bravo bravo
bravo guarda lo guarderò guardalo più
cardano una dato adesso uno portare in
alto il nome della squadra tom vai
allora se mi devo curare e poi si
finisce tempo e angela si acquista jonas
e quindi lui che è un tank e mimì spacca
o cinque secondi prima di ricaricarmi la
vita
porca vacca e ci ho messo una vita a
ucciderti come preside che non riescono
in tre secondi
io direi che giù nel poi me la sento
ancora me la sento ancora adesso ti
accompagno a modo aggressivo con marco
marino porca vacca assomiglio un sacco a
marco quando certi che la barba uguale
dove da sopra la sua prandin già
assassin's creed
anche loro hanno pure però a noi che
cosa ho fatto quasi muovere non ha
ucciso paolo ucciso sono moltissimo sono
fortissima sto gioco perché non sono i
campionati italiani è perché non lo sono
grande azienda che male mi fa che male
minore ragazzino ed non ho fatto niente
ho alzato le mani ha tenuto a bada
signori classista vice l'ordine chi sa
più chi sono più forte io una volta io
ho giocato nello stadio della juventus
ho segnato quanti gol ha fatto cristiano
ronaldo zero sono più forti di cristiano
ronaldo
vola vola vola vola vola skull volo che
io non sono capello preso fare che non
sono capaci
c'è una mira un attimo appurare se
rimango fermo mifur
[Musica]
grande che ha tolto animato ma il mac
tocca a mira che guarda morire primi
polipo ubriaco dove l'altro ho perso il
nemico non vedo non so non sono k non
faccio non l'inizio
io tra di noi sa rà dietro di te ne dite
madonna sembra un ubriaco lo giuro prega
di lo prendi lo questa sfida ma adesso
non ti puro poi voglio la sfida polmare
a verona roma 6 basso eccomi eccomi a
come ci sono stati presi non ora che
prima c'è una miracolata veramente le
sempre dietro ubriaco lo fa meglio
guardali per haga mentre politica una
porca vacca morta dai ti prendo il punto
it home ha vinto va bene no no sono
veramente storto sono storto nella vita
quindi per favore fammi cambiato
premiando manzo manzo rendimento 22
siamo questione cipriani sicilia 3 porca
vacca mai cambiato non è più prima se
non c'è più lasca per cui si sta roba
pari a rancate carico che ti proteggo
che ci deve avere una mira qua vabbè ma
no ma cos'è sta roba loro parola africa
ma cos'è
ma no non mi piace la meglio prima sì
quello fa il giro di tutto santorini si
è schiantata contro il muro non è morta
perché lei toccata ha tirato una testata
l'ho visto da cultura
guarda come sono morte malissimo ha
segnato male
[Musica]
pensavo si dovesse giocare a biliardo
gli fa vedere la guida meglio dai ben e
ti prendono mer si stancherà gnocca
eccoci qua
da questo terrazzino fammi vedere o
arriva uno subito
così il ninja è un problema per tutti
cavalca sicuro sezione aggressivissimo o
in questa difficile
l'hack è male siamo cresce nella
difficiltà non preso due eroi che si ce
ne sono ben ne va bene mi dica lei dai
prova soldato das vendichiamo c soldato
dai posso correre
che bella skill gli altri non lo fanno
semplicemente perché non hanno voglia
non perché bisogna arrivare a terminare
mi prendi che c'è la procura le già
usata era già stato accarezzando io
trovo bene mi è piaciuta un sacco 11
prendendosi da giocare anzi no tu genesi
e con tuffi studiati con lui ci sono
anche chi è o ballo e non ho più la
scrivente andato prepara al pugno
preparatorio morto orca vacca vai
tornavo tom dai ho deciso reihnardt
einaudi o ragazza
avevi già consegnata non c'entrano
niente ma andiamo a remare verso tracer
laggiù in fondo idea ma tu vai proprio
tranquillo te frega niente
brava moglie svenuta non ce l'ha più
voglia là dietro
ma è svenuta nel nulla va bene ma quanto
fiero
sono veramente pronto a qualsiasi tornò
questa ragazza in una mappa che conosco
benissimo perché ho avuto episodi
piacevoli ma la macchina non hanno avuto
prima sperimentarlo e chiedermelo mentre
veniva investito non sembra un ottimo è
stato molto divertente ma non pensavo
che stessero dando va bene comunque non
ci sono macchine guasti sono lì le
macchine ma non mi avvicino neanche per
sbaglio la gente indossare arrivano a
salutarci intanto squilla un telefono
sono sopra
l'hack sopra dove c'è un soprano sala
sopra se
no ci ho creduto troppo dasco muove
questa fama violazione ma che vuol dire
sono entrato in entrata in radio da
presa
bisogna dire con mano ci hanno fatto un
po male ma per poco o c'è dietro dietro
dietro i secondi avevo la cura mannaggia
io io vado sempre fisso perché se sono
forti non ha senso che io cambi no sei
morto
penso io tom ci penso io arrivai con 5
mila gli iscritti guarda ti io ci credo
fortissimo lasciato una trappola per
terra a caso del dato roba bisogna
vendicarsi
va bene e quanto siamo 2 1 a 1 per loro
un cavalca che sia difficile fare
qualcosa lui reynard deve giocare
va bene tel aviv sta menando loro mette
loro metria epoca vita non ho colpito
mai per sbaglio neanche riusciamo andare
noi sopra vieni via vieni dietro di sé
dove sopra patinati matri caricati lo
scudo e sono spariti ricaccia se non ti
misuri cariche stasera abbiamo andiamo
in cima agli amici ma come si fa ad
andare in cima c'è questo è davvero io
ho detto per scherzo e melo mette lui
quegli animali da dietro da dov'era ho
capito cosa è successo qua mi sa che
finirà male a ma sto martello è fatto di
plastica nei che fatto sto coltello ma
dai e quindi ragazzi questa era la pera
e non sto parlando non so sparare non so
parlare però ogni tanto le partite le
vinco anch'io se non fosse stato per me
thomas mack un gas che diventa campione
del mondo dell'italia della liguria di
overwatch però che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi come
mi piace che ha visto che sono stati
fischiati noi ci vediamo
[Musica]